anastasia et daria se connaissent depuis
longtemps elles ont fait leurs études
ensemble en ukraine au conservatoire
national de kiev dès que la guerre a
commencé le 24 février daria accepté que
son ami et sa famille viennent vivre
chez elles anastasia est parti avec sa
soeur marina ses deux nièces maria et
olga et son bébé à lisa ainsi que leurs
chiens et leurs chats en véritable
périple depuis kiev par thomson
reuters à tokyo
le 24 février en série à tous à cause
d'une explosion et on a tous compris que
la guerre a commencé
[Musique]
a dit ding ding ding installé ce matin
jusqu'à mon hôtel majorque est
une journée on en restait accueillir
parce qu'on espérait que c'était pas
vrai que c'était juste
pour nous faire peur non non c'est de
passer
la
nuit suivante ça a explosé encore une
fois déjà tout près de chez nous et on a
entre une voiture on a en partie avec
les parents dans l'ouest de l'ukraine
les deux jeunes femmes ont mis deux
jours pour sortir de la capitale est
arrivé dans un petit village à plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres de la frontière
avec la roumanie en cet arrêté dans une
petit village où les gens gentils nous a
accueillis et on a passé la nuit
on est reparti et juste ces jours là les
temps qu'on rentrait dans cette petite
plage donc on a eu de la chance d partir
exténué enfin arrivés à la frontière de
la roumanie elles ont attendu des heures
pour faire 5 km en a tellement fatigués
on a tellement claqué la seule envie
c'est de s'arrêter quelque part il
dormir parce qu'on n'en peut plus à ces
moments là elles ont dit au revoir à
leurs parents
frères fils marie les moments
extrêmement difficiles
le père de darial lui est en ce moment
au front at yani yves une ville détruite
par les bombardements russes je sais
comment faire
et il est il n'a plus d'électricité n'a
plus de gaz n'a plus de chauffage
sachant qu'il ya une traîne elle fait
froid il neige il n'a pas d'eau potable
n'a pas de froide
on espère tout simplement l évier les
entouraient et peut même pas sortir de
mon côté je fais de mon mieux je fais
tout ce que je peux pour aider ceux qui
ont besoin moi j'organise aussi le
collecte de que ça a commencé la guerre
depuis depuis jeudi vendredi et j'ai
déjà commencé à aller chercher comment
ce que je peux organiser l'aide commence
que je peux organiser
les collectes dans le magasin dans les
pharmacies malgré tout derrière
anastasia et sa famille croit à la fin
de cette guerre pour se donner de
l'espoir elle joue l'hymne de l'ukraine
ça vaut quoi
[Musique]